Patton Oswalt has found love again
[Music]
the 48 year olds comedian is set to Wed
actress Meredith Salinger patins rep
tells et quote they are engaged in love
the bride-to-be shared the news on
Instagram Thursday posting this collage
of photos from the adorable proposal
with Patton and his eight-year-old
daughter Alice writing it's official I'm
the luckiest happiest girl in the
universe the 47 year old also shared an
older pic of her in her man with a pic
of Dwayne the rock Johnson photoshopped
on her left hand she captioned the
hilarious shot quote I don't want to
brag but check out the size of the rock
on my finger the journey of natty Gann
star hinted at an engagement on
Wednesday sharing this throwback writing
once upon a time in 2008 at my friend's
wedding I caught the bouquet
hashtag fairytales do exist
the happy couple made their red carpet
debut in June at the premiere of baby
driver in Los Angeles this will be
Patton's second marriage his wife of 11
years Michelle Lee McNamara died
suddenly just over a year ago in April
of 2016